Сегодня я хотел бы поговорить с вами о
шести причинах Почему у тебя вечно нет
сил и вообще куда уходит ваша жизненная
энергия Мне кажется что эта тема очень
важна для современного человека
практически для каждого из нас почему
эта тема крайне важна и почему надо
досмотреть это видео до конца потому что
энергия - это самый главный ключевой
ресурс любого человека у вас может быть
время у вас может быть цели планы Но
если у Вас нету энергии всё это
бесполезно вы не добьётесь ничего пока
вы не сможете или не научитесь управлять
своей энергией для того чтобы эффективно
управлять своей энергией нужно понять
Какие существуют виды энергии у человека
у человека существует четыре основных
вида энергии Первый вид энергии - это
физическая энергия это базовая энергия
которая является основой для всех
остальных видов второе - это
эмоциональная энергия третье - это
ментальная энергия четвёртое - это
духовная энергия Вы знаете для того
чтобы хорошо Хорошо себя чувствовать
быть воодушевленный проявлять
любопытство исследовать и чего-то
добиваться очень важное значение имеет
ваш уровень эмоциональной и духовной
энергии проблема в том что
а к выгоранию приводят именно отсутствие
эмоциональной энергии прежде всего а
потом и духовной энергии Почему сегодня
я я не затрагивают физической энергией
потому что это более простая Энергия и
как управлять физической энергией
практически знает Каждый из вас хороший
сон правильная еда умеренные физические
физическая активность это всё восполняет
вам физическую энергию А вот
эмоциональная энергия с ней всё гораздо
сложнее для того чтобы понять А что
такое эмоциональная энергия давайте
рассмотрим такой вопрос эмоциональная
энергия за что она отвечает она отвечает
за все наши чувства и все наши ощущения
от этой жизни то есть наши ощущения от
этой жизни наши ощущения полноты жизни
удовлетворённость этой жизнью
чувство радости чувство любви Всё что
касается эмоциональных и чувственных
переживаний за это отвечает
эмоциональная энергия Откуда она
появляется и Что является источником
эмоциональной энергии источниками
эмоциональной энергии является пять
вещей или пять источников Первое - это
достаточная физическая энергия Потому
что если вы уставший голодный холодный
то у вас эмоциональная энергия
позитивная эмоциональная энергия будет
на нуле у вас будет обуревать негативная
эмоциональная энергия второе - это
позитивные эмоциональные ситуации Каждый
раз когда вы ходите на какой-нибудь
Стендап на вечер юмора там или куда-то а
на весёлую вечеринку у вас появляется
увеличивается позитивная эмоциональная
энергия третий источник - это люди
которые создают положительный настрой
поэтому очень важно окружать себ людьми
которые на позитиве которые всё время
относятся к жизни позитивно и ко всем
проблемам относится позитивно четвёртое
- это положительные чувства и ощущения
которые вы сами испытываете которые в
свое очередь зависит от пятого источника
- это позитивного отношения к миру пока
вы не Смените свои убеждения и не
Смените свои очки через которые вы
смотрите на мир на позитивный взгляд вам
будет сложно управлять своей
эмоциональной энергией для того чтобы
управлять энергии существует четыре
основных способа первый самый главный
способ - это сокращение
потерь вашей энергии А дело в том что
каждый день Вы теряете очень много
энергии за счёт
фоновых активностей а
которые забирают буквально высасывают из
вас энергии поэтому сокращение потерь -
это вот знаете Если ваше тело как
дуршлаг из которого там выливается вода
Да но дуршлаг водой вы не наполните тоже
самое если у вас не прекратить утечку
энергии то вы не наполните этой энерги
второе инструмент - это эффективное
использование существующей энергии у вас
уже существующая энергия есть Так вот
нужно научиться её эффективно
использовать третье - это эффективное
восполнение энергии вам нужно научиться
эффективно восполнять энергию которая у
вас потеряна и четвёртое - это
расширение вашего энергетического
потенциала это вот грубо говоря
расширение вашего ковши или
дуршлага для того чтобы больше энергии у
вас было первый инструмент энергии как
вам сокращать потерю энергии для того
чтобы эффективно сокращать потерю
энергии для этого нужно сначала Осознать
что у вас есть потеря энергии потому что
мы живём ежедневной жизнью и как-то само
собой привыкли к тому что у нас
постоянно есть какие-то забирали энергии
и мы с этим живём и на это даже не не
реагируем не осознаём для нас это
является привычным образом жизни поэтому
первое нужно Осознать что у вас есть
потеря энергии второе определить нужно м
нужно определить источники потери этой
энергии и вот сейчас я вам расскажу
шесть основных наиболее частных частых
причин потери вашей эмоциональной
энергии когда я буду вам рассказывать
обязательно это экстраполировать
с вами такое же или нет Я уверен у
каждого это происходит поэтому
Поделитесь в
комментариях какие из этих причин есть в
вашей жизни Итак первая большая причина
потери вашей эмоциональной энергии - Это
неправильный образ жизни банально
неправильный образ жизни это недосып это
недоедание это минимальное физические
нагрузки там ещё что-то Помните я
говорил что для того чтобы у вас
эмоциональная энергия была полная для
этого нужно заботиться о том чтобы
физическая энергия была полная второе
Вторая причина - это страх негативные
мысли желание казаться а не быть на
самом деле это вот эти страшные такие
дырки которые высасывают из вас энергию
вот страх и беспокойство о будущем
особенно сожаление о прошлом вот эти все
моменты они в фоновом режиме высасывают
из вас энергии которую вы даже не
замечаете просто переживание хроническое
переживания страха она лишает вас
огромного количества эмоциональной
энергии потому что человек который
переживает страх стресс негативные мысли
он не может смеяться он не может
расслабляться он всё время напряжён
третья причина - это поведение
неправильное поведение когда Ну вот
например когда работа забирает всё время
когда вы всё время посвящается только
работе Когда у вас отсутствует баланс
баланс разных сфер жизни это работа
семья ваше хобби ваше личное время
должно быть обязательно в течение дня то
есть не надо посвящать Всё своё время
всю свою энергию только одной части
вашей жизни особенно А в поведенческих
причинах Я хотел бы отметить такие вещи
Как незаконченные дела И незакрытые
гештальты то есть если вы какие-то дела
Не законченные не закончили то они
пожирают очень много энергии обязательно
закрывайте заканчивайте дела законченные
Дела высвобождает огромное количество
энергии которое до этого уходило на
контроль или на переживание об этом
многие молодые люди ко мне обращаются и
говорят Ну как же так О каком балансе
может идти речь Если в молодые годы нам
нужно заработать деньги нам нужно
создать бизнес чего-то добиться поэтому
мы специально делаем перекосы и работаем
там по 14-15 часов в день на что я
ответил бы так ну обычно отвечаю так
ребята вопрос в том что вы пытаетесь
компенсировать свою неэффективность за
счёт большего вовлечения И за счёт
больше затрат своей энергии ведь это же
можно было бы компенсировать
эффективностью Если вы занимаетесь
работой 14-15 часов в день то я вам
прямо скажу что вы просто неэффективны
значит вы неправильно выстроили свой
график работы и вы занимаетесь неважным
делами дело в том чтобы для того чтобы
добиваться любых целей в жизни вам
достаточно сти или 8ми часов рабочего
времени смотрите каждый раз обратите
себе внимание на такую вещь Каждый раз
когда вы не укладываете в 8 часов
рабочего времени это говорит только об
одном что вы неэффективны И вам нужно не
увеличивать то время которое вы тратите
на работу А вам нужно увеличивать и
направлять внимание на повышение своей
эффективности внедрить себе каждый час
каждое утро И анализируйте где вы
неэффективны что вы можете делегировать
что вы
можете Может вы вам можно найти
помощника либо не делать какие-то
рутинные вещи какие-то рутинные вещи
передать Если Вы каждый день будете
заниматься повышени своей эффективности
то вам не потребуется тратить так много
времени и энергии на работу приведу вам
Пример дровосека например представим
такую ситуацию что молодой человек
человек говорит мне надо больше рубить
дров поэтому я должен больше заниматься
рубкой деревьев А на что я отвечаю а а
по по моему мнению вам надо больше
времени тратить на то чтобы заточить
топор и ещё больше времени тратить на то
чтобы находить другой способ а рубки
деревьев Возможно там найти бензопилу
или другой метод изобрести и так далее
поэтому не идите на Пу на поводу у
простого решения простое поверхностное
решение просто увеличить количество
времени и энергии которую вы тратите на
бизнес более сложное но эффективное
решение - это подумать над своей
эффективностью четвёртое причина - это
неправильные отношения неправильные
отношения с другими людьми это не
закрытые обязательно
Это неправильно выстроенные ожидания в
отношении других людей это утечка
эмоциональной энергии через встречи и
занятия которые не приносят вашу энергию
вам энергию а наоборот высасывают Вы
наверное сами замечали очень много раз в
жизни когда после какой-то встречи вы
чувствовали себя как выжатый лимон было
это с вами Если это было обязательно
Напишите в комментариях будет интересно
посмотреть на все кейсы которые
происходили в вашей жизни например Когда
вы занимаетесь каким-то делом это дело
вас выматывает
поэтому хороший лайфхак по пути я вам
скажу просто сделайте дневник и пишите
туда Всё чем сегодня в течение дня
занимались и сделайте один столбец
которая гласит энергия эмоциональная
Энергия и пишите на каждый напротив
каждой встречи и напротив каждого дела
которым вы занимались Напишите это вам
принесло энергию или забрало энергию
таким образом вы будете воочию видеть
какие встречи и Какие задачи забирают у
вас энергию и ваша задача каждый день
сокращать количество встреч и задач
которые забирают энергию и увеличивать
количество встреч и задач которые
приносят вам энергию Пятая причина - это
страсти это излишнее потребление это
игры особенно азартные игры это
социальные сети то есть это а любая
зависимость любая форма зависимости
зависание в том же тиктоке в социальных
сетях и из-за этого прокрастинация и
нежелание что-то делать И вообще
социальные сети очень часто вызывают
эффект Фома с английского языка of
missing Out или страх потери или
упущенной жизни вот эти все вещи
являются огромной причиной утечки вашей
эмоциональной энергии и шестая причина -
это внешние причины так как мы не живём
в вакууме Мы живём в социуме то вокруг
нас очень много внешних причин которые
прямо влияют на наше эмоционально Сто
это може могут быть и оскорбления
хамство зависть окружающих осуждение
других людей критика То есть все
действия незнакомых вам людей которые
вылились на вас это там Хамса касира
какого-нибудь может быть продавца и так
далее То есть вы этим управлять не
можете их поведением но мы вы вполне
можете управлять своей реакцией на их
поведение поэтому Когда вы стал
сталкиваетесь с такой
реакцией или с таким поведением
окружающих враждебным поведением в
отношении Вас не пытайтесь исправить их
меняйте своё отношение или меняйте свою
реакцию к этому поведению Таким образом
мы рассмотрели шесть основных причин
конечно же причин гораздо больше но это
основные причины и даже если вы будете
обращать на эти основные причины и
применить применять те лайфхаки и
инструменты которые я вам сегодня
озвучил это гораздо облегчит вашу жизнь